so
[Music]
in the condition of right or law then
the ethical world and the religion of
that world are submerged and lost in the
cosmic consciousness and the unhappy
consciousness is the knowledge of this
total loss
it has lost both the worth that attached
to its immediate personality
and the worth attached to its
personality as mediated
as thought
trust in the eternal laws of the gods
has vanished and the oracles which
pronounced on particular questions
are dumb
the statues are now only stones from
which the living soul has flown just as
the hymns are words from which belief
has gone
the tables of the gods provide no
spiritual food and drink
and in his games and festivals man no
longer recovers the joyful consciousness
of his unity with the divine
the works of the muse now lack the power
of the spirit for the spirit has gained
its certainty of itself from the
crushing of gods and men
they have become what they are for us
now beautiful fruit already picked from
the tree what your friendly fate has
offered us as a girl might set the fruit
before us it cannot give us the actual
life in which they existed not the tree
that bore them not the earth and the
elements which constituted their
substance not the climate which gave
them their particular character nor the
cycle of the changing seasons that
govern the process of their growth
so fate
does not restore their world to us along
with the works of antique art it gives
not the spring and summer of the ethical
life in which they blossomed and ripened
but only the veiled recollection of that
actual world our active enjoyment of
them is therefore
not an act of divine worship through
which our consciousness might come to
its perfect truth and fulfillment
it is an external activity the wiping
off of some drops of rain or specks of
dust from these fruits so to speak one
which erects an intricate scaffolding of
the dead elements of their outward
existence the language the historical
circumstances etc in place of the inner
elements of the ethical life which
environment created and inspired them
and all this we do
not in order to enter into their very
life but only to possess an idea of them
in our imagination
but just as the girl who offers us the
plucked fruits is more than the nature
which directly provides them the nature
diversified into their conditions and
elements the tree air light and so on
because she sums all this up in a higher
mode in the gleam of her self-conscious
eye and the gesture with which she
offers them
so too the spirit of the faith that
presents us with those works of art is
more than the ethical life and the
actual world of that nation for it is in
the inward as ising of in us of the
spirit which in them was still only
outwardly manifested it is the spirit of
the tragic fate which gathers all those
individual gods and attributes of the
divine substance into one pantheon into
the spirit that is itself conscious of
itself as spirit
paragraph
753 is a longer one coming on the heels
of a number of shorter paragraphs
leading us into this revealed religion
section which is the final shape for
religion and you notice that in this
particular paragraph we're going to have
an invocation
of the unhappy consciousness and an
explanation
of what it is so we've got to kind of
revisioning going back to
this earlier section we'll have to talk
about that
in just a moment and we have some
really interesting
observations made on hegel's part about
the
capacity that people have in not just
our own time or hegel's own time but
even earlier
in the the possibility of taking on an
earlier gestalt an earlier
shape of consciousness and not just an
earlier shape of consciousness in a
you might say individualistic let's try
something out form like you know the
law of the heart and the frenzy of
self-conceit which could be done on an
individual basis as well as in a more
cultural societal way
but also forms that themselves are not
just forms of consciousness shapes of
consciousness but you could say
overarching intergenerational
forms of life
which is what the religion of art
represents for us as well as the other
matters that it's connected with in
terms of ethical
life so can we actually go backwards in
what ways can we obviously if we're
referencing it all we can but what are
we actually doing can we
jump back into pagan antiquity and
recover anything remotely like what
pagan antiquity was offering its
worshipers and it's you might say
cultural producers and consumers is that
a possibility
in the presence and i'll say right off
the bat
hegel tells us for example in his
philosophy of history and his history of
philosophy the answer is no
you know at a certain point he says
listen nobody can actually be an
epicurean or a stoic these days and it
goes for other things as well why
because we are in a
radically
different milieu
we'll go back to that in a moment
because i think this raises some
interesting problems for us the 21st
century readers of a hegel who is
writing from a perspective and a culture
that is much more christian
than our own so there's there's a lot to
be
said there and there's also this
beautiful
metaphor to explore of the girl offering
us
a fruit
what does that mean well we'll have to
get into that so
let's start at the start in this
condition of right or law so that's rekt
uh
right um right or law either one is is
fine that's just wrecked and then the
douche on this condition this this um
[Music]
everybody being essentially caught up
within the same matrix all of the
differentiation that was involved in the
ethical world and its religion having
been leveled how how so well hegel talks
a little bit later there of um
you know the the gods and men having
been brought low right so that's an
example of this it also ties in with
this comic
consciousness uh you know which is
essentially
not a
everything so funny but more of a
sardonic bitter consciousness which
corresponds to a significant degree to
what is going on in certain parts of the
spirit section
as well and what hegel thought was was
happening in some of the comic
literature of his own time but also
happening
in ancient times
what would be examples of this i think
the the prime example would be the
satirican of petronius arbiter right if
you wanted to pick a
particular thing there's all sorts of
crazy stuff happening and people are
trying to seek their
their meaning to life and then there's
this encounter with the sybil that
anybody who's read the work it's stuck
with them you know somebody sees the
sybil in a jar at kume and asks what do
you want and the sybil this oracle says
i want to die the ancient world
was in many respects
falling apart
this is something that often gets left
out by those who want to have a return
to antiquity right they first of all
generally don't know enough about
antiquity so they laud the spartans even
though the spartans would kill them on
first sight or they think they want to
go back to ancient athens or ancient
rome
but they also don't realize the
hollowing out
of that culture that that hegel has
pointed out through the developments in
the religion of art right and also back
in the spirit section
so a lot being said there let's go on
with the text in this condition of
writer law the ethical world right it's
an entire vote and the religion of that
world are submerged lost in the comic
consciousness
and the unhappy consciousness here hegel
is revaluing
what the unhappy consciousness is about
is the knowledge
of this total
loss
loss of the ethical world
loss of what the earlier religion could
provide that's why you move to the
unhappy consciousness that's why
for example
judaism could attract all sorts of
non-jews to its
worship and celebrations that's why
christianity could spread that's
probably also why manichaeism connected
to christianity could spread throughout
the
empire and we could we could chart this
out in a larger sense if we wanted to on
a world historical basis but we'll we'll
put that aside for the moment because
hegel doesn't doesn't do that
what is the unhappy consciousness if we
go back to the un unhappy consciousness
section
what we see over and over again
is
that the human being and the human
beings together
have realized that there's something
greater than what they had previously
thought and they project it outside of
themselves as an a religious object as
something to be
worshipped as something to be united
with is something to be served as we
could go on and on go back to the
unhappy consciousness section if you
want to review that there's many
different modalities all the way to
bells and smells as we sometimes joke
about within uh you know liturgical
christianity talking about people using
sensors and bells and things like that
which hegel talks about
what is the goal it is to
recover
a relationship with the divine that is
part of oneself that is
humanity writ large projected out there
but we're not realizing that now how did
we arrive
at that point earlier on in the
self-consciousness section
well
we first had the master slave dialectic
and we've got you know production and
development of consciousness then we
have stoicism which we've already talked
about just a little bit in this this
other section and then we have
skepticism and skepticism is another
shape of what hegel here is calling the
comic consciousness right that we
concluded the last section with and then
we move into
the unhappy consciousness so that is a
essentially a social philosophical
progression
here we have a religious progression a
religious progression tied in with a way
of life an overarching
cosmos that we are connected with and in
which the gods and and we you know move
and and have our being you could say and
and are shaped in this this pantheon
and that's lost
and the unhappy consciousness
is the consciousness
of that loss
fearless
a total loss
right and what is this total loss hegel
is going to specify this to us it has
lost both the worth it attached to its
immediate personality and here he
actually uses the term zelpstvet right
so it's it's not
worth its
valuation of self that it attached to
its immediate personality personality
right
and also as uh
attached to
it mediated uh and as thought as thought
as something that is
thought not as thinking as gaddaft right
so
the unhappy consciousness
is an advance but it's an advance into
the
negative it sure as hell doesn't feel
good to be the unhappy consciousness
it's
right it's unhappy so
what has it actually
lost
here's where
we get a whole listing and
hegel's being comprehensive here
rather than just sketching a few things
he actually runs through a number of
matters trust in the eternal laws of the
gods
has vanished
so you know the divine law that was
there
what else the oracles which pronounced
on particular questions
are dumb they have nothing to say
the statues are now only stones from
which the living soul has flown the
statues still exist the oracle still
exists
but there's nothing there anymore
just as the hymns are words from which
belief
has gone all of these wonderful
hymns that we have preserved to apollo
to
demeter to zeus to pick whoever you want
none of them mean
anything
as hymns anymore they can be looked at
as you know wonderful poetry
but they're not what they used to be
what else the tables of the gods provide
no spiritual food and drink and here
we're talking not just about tables set
out in front of us we're talking about
the
cult which played such a massively
important role earlier on throughout the
entire religion section the cult was a
massive achievement
and now
it's no longer
providing what it used to right a sort
of communion between gods and human
beings
we could say the same thing about the
architecture we could say the same thing
about the decorations
in his games and festivals man no longer
recovers the joyful consciousness of his
unity with the divine the games and
festivals still go on
but now there's something worldly rather
than something transcendent
finally the works of the muse
now lack the power of
the
what were the works of the muse well
these new forms of language
epic poetry
tragedy
and comedy
why well we saw this happen in the
previous
uh section the spirit has gained its
certainty of itself from the crushing
of gods and men
and what is what do all these things
become here's the the next
side of it
they have become what they are for us
now so hegel is saying
something not just about what happens in
the ancient world in this transition to
different forms of religion he's also
talking about us
and a good question we can ask ourselves
is does the us that hegel is discussing
does it manage to extend itself to us
two centuries
uh you know in advance or are we a bit
too different
now right
so he says um
what what have they become
beautiful fruit
already picked
from the tree the fruit is no longer on
the tree the fruit has been
picked so it's ripe which a friendly
fate a shikhzal has
offered us
as a girl might set the fruit before us
and this girl is going to come back in
just a moment we'll have to say what the
girl is but first what is
the fruit well the fruit is something
that we can
regard something that we can consume but
we can't actually have the totality
of the fruit we can't have
to use a word that hegel is not bringing
in here it in terms of
in terms of the totality of things that
have gone
into it that we could conceptualize and
what do these include well obviously the
tree
it can't give us the tree that bore them
and this is something worth thinking
about you know um
you cannot get
the hours and hours of thought and
rewritings and reflection
and
dead ends that produced this book
that hegel brought forth right
that's the this is the fruit
we don't get the tree
i mean we get
hegel is kind of a tree we see him
producing other things that's kind of
nice
but
we don't have anything of the the tree
itself and you know in a way this is a
bit of a side note
we often measure our own thought as
philosophers or as students of
philosophy against these greats who we
encounter
and we you know read hegel or we read
descartes or we read aristotle or we
read pick whoever else you want and
we're like oh my gosh they are so smart
compared to us boy i you know rarely
have three good thoughts in a day look
at this this is like a cornucopia of
brilliant thoughts or perhaps you know
maybe brilliant but i'm not quite sure i
understand them but people say they're
brilliant right
well this is because we're looking at
the finished product
it's sort of like
judging
a
you know
lp album
produced in the studio by a band and
then looking at all the noodling and
playing around with riffs and
false starts and now let's get rid of
this section of the song i know we got
to put in a drum track
these are two different things right so
the tree is is one thing that they're
missing but there's more than just a
tree right
it cannot give us uh the
the
tree
and then um
what else it cannot give us
uh the tree that bore them not the earth
and the elements which constituted their
substance what what was taken in
to the fruit
we know that plants are
things that react to their environment
right
actually in terms of
some things we might even have animals
involved in some way we certainly have
pollinators involved but sometimes you
know there's there's wasps and figs and
things like that
nor the climate
which gave them their particular
character what in wine making
they call terroir right the terrain the
the landscape in which these grapes
grow
this way because you know the sun shines
in a certain way and there's a certain
amount of rain and the soil has certain
elements in it and there's certain pests
and a lack of other certain pests all
that goes into making the fruit
what it is
even beyond that
not the cycle
of changing seasons that govern the
process of their growth
the
temporality
is not there in the fruit either i mean
it produced the fruit it's the product
of a an end process of temporality right
but we don't have that time
that it took other than perhaps you know
fruit that's been raised too quickly
may taste mealy it doesn't have the
fullness of its possibilities
it's been done artificially it has to
have been done in some respect naturally
coming back to
a little bit earlier in this
he tells us
that this friendly fate
has offered us the fruit as a girl might
set the fruit before us it cannot give
us the actual life
vehicle
in which
these things existed
right
he goes on and says
fate does not restore
their world to us along with the works
of antique art it does not give it gives
not the spring
and summer of the ethical life in which
they blossomed
and ripened now spring and summer
these are the actual seasons
for growing fruit right
at first the fruit is merely a blossom
that has to be pollinated right there
has to be this this process of
reproduction then we have summer the
fruit begins to grow and the sun is
shining down and things are happening
within the fruit the tree is
contributing to it and only then in the
the fall well i mean there's summer
fruit of course but let's just stick to
this only then in the fall
is it ripe enough for us to take it and
the summer and the spring are gone
well
this is an interesting metaphor for
cultural production is it not
so he says
all we get is the veiled
recollection of that actual world that
was a real world the people of antiquity
were real human beings they may not have
realized spirit in the way that we do in
the present or even
the way that was done say in the
enlightenment
or in the unhappy consciousness but they
were real they were real human beings
they had something to preoccupy them
something gave their lives centrality
and meaning and for many it was this
form of religion or the many forms of
religion that fit into this super form
of religion
so
what do we do why
what happens when we're talking about
this you know when i when i teach a
religions of the world class and we talk
about ancient greek and roman uh
religion
and you know there's always somebody
who's like yeah i'm i'm really into
hellenism and you know you kind of look
at them and you're like
yeah that ain't that ain't what what was
being practiced back then you know same
thing with people who are like oh i'm
reviving norse religion
well i mean hegel would say without an
ethical world that's not really feasible
you can cosplay you can larp doing that
sort of thing but it's not really the
same thing and instead what's a better
perspective on this appreciation right
he tells us
our active enjoyment of them we can have
active enjoyment of of all this stuff of
oracle statues hymns these tables games
and festivals works of the muse i mean
some
a little bit less than the others works
of the muse tends to be what we
concentrate on and very often we're just
reading these in text form we're not
having a bard recite homer to us
in our you know dimly lit
hall or something like that at a
festival we're not actually watching
the uh tragedies played out on the stage
but you know we can get some idea of it
and we can appreciate it and we can read
hymns and get something out of it
but what do we get out of it he says
this is not an act of divine worship
through which our consciousness might
come to its perfect truth and
fulfillment
it is an external activity
what we're getting out of it from the
perspective of the unhappy consciousness
is an external activity
uh he says the wiping offs of some drops
of rain or specks of dust from these
fruits so to speak
one which erects an intricate
scaffolding of the dead elements of
their outward existence
so we we do a scaffolding and this is
quite a you know hegel's attuned to this
you can't just pick up homer and start
going to town or walk around and look at
greek statuary and be like oh like in
the louvre for example there's all sorts
of cool greek statuary
you need to know something about that
ethical world in order to more fully
appreciated any yeah i mean
interestingly with statuary we also know
that you have to imagine
these things as painted
not in the pristine white forms that we
see them with right these were actually
painted statues and you have to imagine
that colorfulness that motliness right
so
how do we do that hegel brings up two
things as example uh language
right if you want to understand plato
it helps to learn greek you know if you
want to understand
something having to do with rome i mean
a lot of them actually wrote in greek
because there was a kind of inferiority
complex
in relation to greek on the part of
latin speakers where do we learn this
from a great example that is cicero who
talks about it over and over again as he
attempts to undo that now notice what
we're doing here we're filling in
background stuff
so talking about language
but also talking about the historical
the historicia right
here miller translates this
as historical circumstances but it goes
beyond your circumstances
knowing uh some things about the
background and real things not just
stuff from wikipedia
uh not just you know things from memes
or god forbid from inaccurate television
or um you know movies or things like
that
well it really helps you appreciate it
and interestingly there's a bit of a
side note if all you have is a
consumption of basically
fake antiquity stuff that's oriented in
the culture wars of today
you would go to the louvre and you
wouldn't be able to appreciate the
statues in the way that
somebody who actually knows something
about ancient times wood same thing goes
for the medieval time same thing goes
for oriental pit orientalizing pictures
of uh you know things happening in india
or china with you say buddhist art you
really gotta actually know something in
order to appreciate don't you
so going on
he says
um
these are
these things are what we use in place of
the inner elements of the ethical life
which environ created and inspired them
right there was a process of
internal development that took place
that we can only kind of pick at on the
outside
now here he talks about the girl
just as the girl who offers us the pluck
fruits is more
than the nature which directly provides
them the nature diversified into their
conditions elements the tree air light
so on why because she sums all this up
in a higher mode
now notice the way she t that hegel
talks about this
in the gleam of her self-conscious eye
and in the the gesture the beard with
which she offers
them
so too right so we've got
a girl not just mechanically
offering us fruit but
aware of herself
as
preferring
these things to us as engaging in a
gesture as having a gleam in her eye as
having intentionality and agency
what's the girl in this case
well the girl is fate but now he calls
it the spirit the geist
of the fate that presents us with these
works of art why does it present us with
these works of art because this is part
of our you know our background our
heritage whatever we want to call it
right it's something that we have access
to more or less i mean so much of
antiquity has been lost right
the spirit of faith that presents us
with these works of art is more than the
ethical life and the actual world of
that nation
and here's where there's an interesting
play on words
for it is the inwardizing in us of the
spirit which in them was still only
outwardly
manifested
inwardizing
is
right
inner going inside but
also means something like remembering or
recollection there is a possibility of
recollection
available to us that of course was not
available to those who were living it
because i mean they could remember what
happened in their lifetime and they
could remember memorial events like oh
the battle of marathon oh so good you
know
we have a different sort of
going on a different sort of
memorializing
in our own time
in relation to these these works of of
art the fruits
and
he goes on and he says
it is the spirit of the tragic fate
which gathers all those individual gods
and attributes of the divine substance
into one pantheon
into the spirit that is itself conscious
of itself
as spirit now you notice we're already
in talking about that we're kind of
moving
past the unhappy consciousness there at
the end of this
paragraph and of course this is
just the beginning of this section there
is this hint that
we are able to appreciate
and to grasp
all this stuff in the past which might
also include for some of us the unhappy
consciousness
and we're also
able to grasp
the the spirit that is itself conscious
of itself as spirit and advance that is
taking place
so this is pretty important stuff that's
going on here
in this section this is already quite
long but i do want to close by raising
one interesting issue the unhappy
consciousness right we can't have access
according to hegel to the ethical worlds
of the past in the sense of those who
were
living them
and we could talk about those that are
closer to him in time a broken ethical
world for example of the enlightenment
that he is part of although hegel is
also part of what you can call an
enlightenment critical enlightenment
what i i've called in the past the
second enlightenment
but the unhappy consciousness in some
respects looks like it's you know much
much earlier maybe extends into the
middle ages
can we really belong to that sort of
ethical community or spiritual community
if we've gotten past the zit leak of the
ethical community of the ancient world
can we really belong to that today can
we be trads as they say
and you know lament the burning of notre
dame you know uh or any any of these
these sorts of things as if we were
members of that and i think hagel would
say
well
not really
not we can't really be the unhappy
consciousness
in its original sense but maybe there's
another
formulation or reworking of it that's
going on
in
this entire section
you